[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
or is that first think of it Dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast where me
Hank green and my brother John we answer
your questions give you dubious advice
and bring you all the week's news from
both Mars and AFC Wimbledon the first
thing that I say on this podcast after
the intro is John how are you doing I'm
doing wonderfully and I'll tell you why
it's a very simple thing but it's a huge
deal
Hank for the first time in the history
of our podcast last week we made no
major errors like we got no we got no
correction emails we got some correction
emails from people pointing out that the
the song the Devil Went Down to Georgia
is not actually about accountants but I
thought that was clear in context so I
think that we technically no Corrections
no flaws a flawless performance last
week from both Hank and John I can
guarantee you one thing that won't
happen again this week oh no no
definitely not we're gonna do our best
to make as many mistakes as possible you
know John I got a correction on Twitter
who knows who who said that that I
mispronounced lacroix but in fact I did
not
oddly enough so I also thought that
Lacroix was pronounced Lacroix because
it's got all those extra letters in it
so I figured that it was French but in
fact Lacroix is made in America by the
st. Croix River which has spelled CR o
IX and is pronounced Croix so yep it's a
Mary it's not French and they say on the
website it says right there it's
pronounced Lacroix like enjoy
apparently oh that's adorable and
wonderful news because it means that I
still I get to read an actual short poem
today instead of a short poem of
Correction which I'm very excited about
all right do it alright Hank I thought
I'd read a little bit of a dark poem but
you know this is a comedy podcast about
death so here's complete destruction by
William Carlos Williams it was an icy
day we buried the cat then took her box
and set fire to it in the backyard those
fleas that escaped earth and fire died
by the cold
complete destruction by William Carlos
Williams you know John I have some
trivia about William Carlos Williams to
get us started I probably know it was it
that he was a physician and often wrote
his poems on prescription notes nope it
is about how he was a physician he
believed and he prescribed in addition
to prescribing poems he prescribed
yogurt baths well uh follow-up point
while William Carlos Williams was
probably wrong about yogurt baths he was
right about yogurt lots of probiotics or
at least some yogurt has products in it
yeah in fact in fact he would also he
would often recommend that people would
get yogurt enemas oh boy okay let's move
on to some questions from our listeners
the the thing that I'm doing right now
John is making up fake stuff so I
thought that you would catch on to that
oh no no no but you can't you can't
correct yourself mid pod it ruins it
right also people who stopped listening
the moment you said yogurt enemas are
now going to walk around for the rest of
their lives and be like you know that
guy who wrote the red arrow and you
won't believe this but yeah I guess we
can't I guess I I thought that it was
completely unbelievable but you never
know no I totally I totally bought it
because you know like 20th century
medicine especially pre-world War Two
was bananas sometimes literally well
John before we get to the questions I
just want to say the word Lacroix a
couple more times in an effort to to
maybe clue in Lacroix that there might
be a podcast interested in sponsorship
though I'll be honest well I have brand
affinity for Lacroix and I would not for
example work with Dasani sparkling water
because like you can't get in on this
thing I'm sorry you know major Cola
brands this is gonna have to be a
separate thing that you will not and in
fact there's Dasani sparkling water in
my office right now and I'm really angry
about it but Poehler that would also be
fine
Seagram's totally down with that Eddy
you guys want to reach out I'm a big
sparkling water fan and I think it's all
about you know the fact that sugar is
gonna kill you if yeah it's just a
dangerous substance that is very
addictive and that I like very do almost
100% Hank the only thing I
disagree with is that like I think there
are some configurations of sugar that
can actually of course be really helpful
you know there are times when you need
those quick simple carbohydrates and I
think dismissing that entirely
you know dismisses the nutritional value
of Snickers bars and that's offensive to
me person John ah I see I see what you
see what you're saying here oh well I
think that maybe we should leave this
conversation up to dr. Aaron Carroll at
healthcare triage youtube.com slash
healthcare triage we're just leveraging
things to promote more things are
constant begging for corporate
sponsorship is the most reprehensible
part of this podcast and that's really
saying something
alright John I got a questions from Emma
who asks dear Hank and John my birthday
was a few days ago and I got a bunch of
great shirts from dftba.com Oh Emma you
know how to get a question answered you
know how to get a question answered
auntie Reagan John don't you but Emma
continues hello I need some advice what
is the appropriate etiquette when people
are singing happy birthday to you do you
smile and nod do you sing along and sing
happy birthday to yourself or do you
just sit there I have no idea what to do
to avoid the awkward birthday scenario
any advice even dubious is welcome
alright Hank when it comes to this stuff
and also so much other stuff I look to
the Queen of England because like every
time the Queen of England appears in
public it's sort of similar to what it's
like on your birthday when people are
singing happy birthday to you like
everybody's paying a lot of attention to
the Queen of England everybody's always
singing a song that has her name in it
called god save the queen and the way
that she responds is smiling the
occasional wave so I think when people
are singing you happy birthday you just
smile you listen you're attentive you
try to make eye contact with as many
people as possible but not in a creepy
way and then at an opportune moment
maybe when they say your name and the
happy birthday song you know happy
birthday to Emma that's when you go for
the just the real relaxed Queen wave I
don't you just like I'm doing it right
now you can't say honestly wreaking
amazing
Queen Elizabeth wait I couldn't I
couldn't not as you were saying and
we're just John and I are sitting in
different parts of America right now
making our hands do dumb stuff I know
there's nothing dumb about the Queen
whoa I apologize job
I apologize for insulting the Queen the
Queen wave I know that you are a big fan
of the Queen wave and that you have a
poster on your wall that says the Queen
wave and it's just the Queen's hand and
it's framed and it's gonna make it
$1,000 frame around it and and they used
to hang in a gallery of Queen waves and
and I know it's a big deal in your life
but so I so I deeply apologize I mean I
know your true I know you're trying to
create a world in which people will
correct us but that all everything you
just said is true I am like a proper
monarchist I I don't think it's adequate
just for the Queen to be seen as the
head of state
I think the Queen should be the queen of
the world like I think she should be the
person who decides what is done in the
world at all time well I honestly think
that it would be pretty cool to have a
world royal and and the queen is as
close yeah for sure just not necessarily
somebody who makes decisions but
somebody that we're all just sort of
like there for and we're like you know
that's a cool thing that we've got a
world Queen and they have this you know
sort of like fantastically large stipend
but not sort of like any larger than any
other rich person but we all sort of see
them as you know the royalty I think
that's a good idea and I would like to
nominate my wife oh that's very sweet
but unfortunately that job is already
taken by the great Queen Elizabeth the
second and stop trying to dethrone her
she is the greatest monarch of our time
or anytime
she's very great which is pretty great I
you know a little concern that we've
we've gotten somewhat away from the
question right well hi well we all do
this next time you're at a birthday
party
with someone that you respect and and
think is that their car they're
comfortable in every situation just
watch them and see what they do because
I don't even know I'm just like I'd like
focus on the cake focus on the cake
focus on the cake yeah but you don't you
don't sing along to your own birthday so
no does the there's the queen sing god
save the queen because that would be
funny I don't know if the Queen is
I clean because I've kind of set myself
up rhetorically during this bit be an
expert to make it seem like I know a lot
about the Queen when in fact the major
things I know about her are that she is
English and that she is old and that a
bunch of people seem to really like her
all right John do you wanna start have
any other I just wanted to do the dftba
College on it's the only reason Emma got
our answer questions right you know what
you know what you can get at dftba.com
Hank that I keep meaning to mention is
AFC Wimbledon scarves that are genuinely
awesome and the money the royalties from
the scarves go to AFC Wimbledon and
they're only like ten dollars or
something so yeah while we're while
we're selling out go to dftba calm get
an AFC Wimbledon scarf okay we have
another question this one comes from Tim
who writes Dear John and Hank when I
recently went to a performance by the
Chicago Symphony Orchestra I immediately
realized that the majority of the people
there were senior citizens
I'm currently 19 which means there were
a few people of my age attending the
concert my question is what kind of
music do you think those currently in
their teens will be listening to in the
future will we be seeing an elderly
Justin Bieber Taylor Swift or even Hank
green performing at Carnegie Hall in the
distant future will people listen to
classical music in 2066
oh well I would be happy to play
Carnegie Hall in 2066 and in fact I
would like to reach out to Carnegie Hall
right now and say can i book a date
sometime in 2016 6 do you have anything
available and is it possible I could
lock in a rate right now I mean let's
face it Hank
it the reason the main reason it would
be awesome for you to play Carnegie Hall
in 2066
is that it would mean that you're still
alive there's a pretty good chance we'll
be alive when I'm 86 I don't know that
I'll be able to oh you're such an
optimist I don't know be able to stand
up in front of a rube for an hour and
not poop my pants if I play one song and
be like I'll be right back young you
know young young 50 year olds and 60
year old I like this question go take
care of some business I like this
question because
I of course wondered this when I was a
teenager and now I find myself 20 years
removed from teenage earnest and what
has happened in our case Hank is that
the bands that we thought were too like
cool and progressive and important to
ever be considered classic rock or
oldies nonetheless are now oldies like
yes we are now as far removed from
Nirvana's Nevermind as teenage me was
from sergeant pepper's Lonely Hearts
Club and that is something else so what
happens is that the music you like gets
normalized and it starts playing in
grocery stores and a new generation of
old people will like classical music in
20 years and 40 years and 60 years
because I don't think people like
classical music because it was popular
when they were young because it wasn't I
think they liked classical music because
as they get older they you know just
value and treasure it more on average
that's my guess anyway yeah I mean I
think that it takes a certain amount of
exposure and also patience to enjoy
classical music in a fast-paced world
where there's lots of new music always
coming out and I have found myself
enjoying classical music more still not
listen to classical music stations or
anything but I could see myself in in 30
years doing it and I listen to jazz more
and I also think that we are all very
lucky though it might seem a little bit
unpleasant you know that moment when you
hear 21 pilots on the oldies station is
when you know that you know at least you
didn't die you might be old now but
what's the alternative is that you
didn't make it this far at least you
made it to be become an oldie oh that's
gonna be that's gonna be something I
don't know it's it's it's there's no
there's no easy way to get old though
Hank it's just it's it's it's an
undignified process oh yeah well you
know yes but I think that you can you
could there's place two ways to find
dignity there are lots of dignified old
people no I'm just saying for me I
suspect that it's going to
I'm gonna whack I don't have a ton of
dignity as it is I'm not going into
middle-age with like you know
overwhelming amounts of dignity so I'm a
little concerned well I think I think
it's something you might develop you
don't you might not have dignity right
now John but maybe it's something that
you're gonna have in the future right
maybe I'll keep my fingers crossed oh
let's move on to another question so
keep my fingers crossed for your dignity
John this one is from Haley who asks
dear Hank and John what food group do
mushrooms fall into they don't seem like
they would be fruits or vegetables but
then I looked up in the dictionary the
definition of a vegetable and it claims
that all plants used as food are
vegetables which would make fruits also
vegetables basically I'm very confused
and hoping that you can clear some
things up for me what do you think John
yeah no I this is a common question and
the answer of course is that mushrooms
are not food that's definitely not true
oh no it is you can you I mean you can
eat mushrooms in the same sense that
like you know you can eat Legos if you
want to but it doesn't make it food well
the thing that makes mushrooms food is
that they contain calories you could
just eat mushrooms and survive I maybe
not forever but for longer than if you
were just eating Legos mmm I think you
could probably live for a few months on
Legos I'd like to see some science on
how long you could live on Legos I think
you need a new pair of teeth pretty
quick or maybe a new did I say pair of
teeth okay I didn't I didn't pick the
best non-food item I'll admit okay like
obviously if I could go back and pick a
better example of a non-food item I
would like for instance notebook paper
would have been better because that is
more easily digestible than like [ __ ]
with Legos I'm gonna say Legos have
calories you could eat them and they
would provide some level of sustenance
for some period of time I did and that
is a hill that I am ready to fight and
die you know it depends on the Lego John
if it's been sitting in a box for a long
time and maybe there are some bugs
hiding in the little nooks and crannies
of the Legos there may be some some
calories in Legos but I think if you
water it down enough it'll it'll get
mushy but let's get back to Haley
question Hank are mushrooms vegetables
or fruits or is this all a construct and
none if it actually matters well yeah I
mean it depends on who you ask
it is of course all the contract another
if it really matters which is you know
the the definition of life on earth here
as a human but mushrooms they are their
own thing as you say according to the
dictionary any any plant that you can
eat is quote a vegetable but mushrooms
are not vegetable or not plants they are
they are fungi they are a whole
different part of the biological tree
they broke off from the rest of all like
animals they broke off from animals
after we broke off from plants so we are
more closely related to funguses than we
are to than we are to plants but Wow
but I did look this up and the USDA
which decides to some extent what is a
what is a
you know counts is like the food group
you know it is what we're talking about
we're not talking about like biological
classifications we're talking about food
groups the USDA says that they are a
vegetable that they that eating
mushrooms falls into your fruits and
vegetable category for the day and this
is because the USDA stands for US
Department of Agriculture and there is a
Department of the United States
government that is responsible for it
deciding what we eat and they do not
represent Americans they represent
Americans who grow food and I think this
is extremely strange that it is
basically this is an organization that
is out for the basically to cater to the
interests of farmers and they they're
trying telling people what to eat not
for the health of the people but for the
health of the agriculture industry this
is very weird and so they put it you
know they like things like you know
you're drinking like orange juice and it
tells you that it's a certain number of
servings of fruit that's those servings
of fruit are about sales of oranges not
about the personal health of the
individual it is it is rule OODA Chris
and something that infuriates me
whenever I see people talk about
servings of fruits and vegetables but
yes they the fungi are regulated by the
USDA and they were like put us in there
somewhere people
after they have a reason to eat
mushrooms and they go in their roots and
vegetables cuz they serve a lot of the
same purpose they're healthy they're
low-calorie they have high fiber and
they have a lot of vitamins and minerals
they're very good for you and it in case
anyone was wondering John and I
completely disagree about this and they
are delicious I love God I don't love
all mushrooms they taste like the dirt
from which they came not a huge fan of
those like button ones that they know
that they like slice up on the pizzas I
don't love those ones but there's so
many different kinds of mushrooms with
so many different kinds of flavors and a
really great meat alternative as well
because they also have a lot of protein
but they're just a great food they're
great food and don't diss mushrooms John
but you can just the USDA and I will I
just want to clarify one thing Hank
which is that not all of the dietary
guidelines released by the government
are released by the USDA there are now
for instance there's the office of
disease prevention and health promotion
which you can find their dietary
guidelines at health.gov oh well look at
you that feels like a really good
corporate sponsor there John health gov
seems like something that we shouldn't
be ashamed of man if health gov would
just send me 378 healthy bodies that
would be amazing
it's like pop into one get it really
unhealthy pop into the next one get that
one really unhealthy
well gee 378 Snickers bars in two days
well tell you what the key is being able
to inhabit 14 bodies each day you got it
yeah you need a lot more Snickers bars
now that you have 378 human bodies to go
through alright Hank I have another
question this one comes from Brendan who
asks why do eyebrows matter so much to
people I mean there are literally just
little strips of body hair above your
eyes and so many people are obsessed
with them I just don't understand why
they matter so much Hank you might guess
why I wanted to ask this question it's
because lots of people in comments of
our YouTube videos are talking about my
eyebrows and how they are reportedly
thinning and it's super annoying and it
reminds me that if I were a woman on the
internet instead of a man I would be
subjected to constant endless analyses
of my physical body in ways that I would
find completely destructive
and would make it impossible for me to
continue making things on the Internet
so yeah that's totally why I'm asking
this question III knew I knew nothing
about I had never thought about your
highbrows until I watched watch that
video and then I was like spent the hilt
like cuz I like looked at the comments
people talk put your eyebrows and I look
at a dry rose that I'm like hi they're
kind of weird and I looked at my video
and I was like Maya is it kind of weird
do that pretty far apart we got pretty
far apart eyebrows John and I got that
thing going where eyebrows are pretty
far apart right and then you start to
get in this like cycle of panic where
you're like oh that's it my career is
over my eyebrows are further apart than
they used to be and boy you know like on
wax how do you wax eyebrows someone get
me a candle I know or I I do so I do I
do pull my eyebrow hair out sometimes
compulsively a part of OCD thing that I
have but but I haven't lately it's been
pretty pretty well controlled actually
so it's curious to me that now is the
time that it's that it's coming up but I
don't know why they matter so much to
people Brendan except that I think it
frames the eyes for people and people
like looking at eyes that's where people
are usually looking they're looking at
the thing that's looking at them and the
so the eyebrows are sort of in your
peripheral vision if you're staring
intently into someone's eyes so that's
my theory
about it but but I don't know man I I
also feel like eyebrows are a little
overrated yeah I mean faces are nice we
like them and it is interesting that we
have eyebrows at all they seem to be not
not just physically functional but also
socially functional it's one of the
adaptations that we have that seems
clear that it is a thing that we have
for to help communication and so to
express emotion and even communicate
non-verbally or over long distances and
so like we develop these things to
increase our ability to read the cues of
other humans which helped us be humans
and that's that's weird that's a cool
thing that we have these structures on
our faces that
if you like took them out of context
would be quite weird like it's just this
fuzzy thing that like sits on top of
your brow line and this little
caterpillars that you got up there
that's weird that's weird just like you
know how many of them if you took it up
context of our body parts are weird like
one of the things that I find most
terrifying in the world John is thinking
about animals with human hands on them
instead of having having feet you know
like if you think about like a horse
with human hands it's just like human
hands are kind of terrifying when
they're anywhere except on a human body
yeah but you know it's all it's all a
construct and and I wish I wish that we
didn't analyze ourselves so harshly John
as people I do occasionally have these
moments I don't know if you have these
moments Hank where I'm able to zoom out
and see human bodies like the way other
animals might or at least like it in a
way that doesn't feel like human to me
and I'm always just like look at these
look at these ludicrous bodies and these
and these weird people obsessing over
them like they're so concerned with
their bodies it's amazing yeah III do
have those moments it's like when you
say a word long enough and you're like
this word doesn't actually it's not a
word yeah it's like when you like if you
can get into the right mind you're like
that is a weird shape for a thing to be
yeah look at people they're so weird
you're weird naked hairless things yeah
yeah I think it's I think it's mostly
our lack of fur that I find so
distressing
we're very weird looking like just you
know if you compare us to all the other
Apes we're by far the weirdest ones like
Apes must look at us like I bet like an
orangutan looks at chimpanzee and it's
like yeah I get it
I get it you're not bad and then
orangutan looks at a human and it's just
like what is going on with you man what
is this what did you do what happened
you're mad and disgusting are you okay
dude he did you see that some kind of
original sin yes all right
this question is from Paul John who asks
dear Hank and John there
our hand soaps and there are facial
soaps isn't really necessary that I have
both I think that I wash my hands and
face a healthy amount and always use one
or the other I feel like having two is
unnecessary does it really matter which
one I use is there any real evidence for
having different soaps for different
body parts Hank I'm gonna be honest with
you and say that this question Falls way
out of my fields of expertise well it is
different I'll say that those soaps are
different there are different things you
know we like soap but it's very basic is
just a detergent agent you know if you
just have like the cheapest
off-the-shelf
like dish soap it's just detergent and
that you know like bangs up and breaks
stuff and it makes it easier to wash
oils in particular off of things but
also whether it like just anything and
that's that's like what soap used to be
and we have added things to soap and
that's those things that we add make
them more expensive and so the basic
idea is that hand soap is a more like
more primitive rather than I might not
be the right word primitive kind of soap
that since your hands are pretty tough
and they can handle it but face soap
might have them like less of the
detergent it might have more of some
things like conditioners that that that
sort of replace the oils that they might
wash away from your face and make your
face not for you all dry and gross and
that's obviously the same thing with
shampoo it has it has
you know detergent to get rid of all the
stuff but then it actually replaces some
of the stuff that it got rid of with
them some basically like you know
conditioning agents that are in a way
they're like a new kind of oil that you
were putting back into your hair to
replace the oil that you just stripped
away and there's also all kinds of other
stuff you know you might have
moisturizers you might have like sudsing
compounds that make it look suds ear and
so you can like feel it and like enjoy
the sudsy feeling which doesn't actually
have anything to do with the so penis
the soap chemistry is fascinating and
there are lots there's lots that go into
the different kinds of soaps that we
have which is why a face soap which is
trying to be more careful with your skin
might be much more expensive than hand
soap also of course the marketing that
goes into that is expensive as well so
there is a difference but if you wash
your face with hands
open that doesn't bother you don't spend
extra money on face soap and certainly
do not wash your hands with face soap
unless you have really sensitive skin
because because that's just kind of
that's just gonna put a hole right in
your bank accounts gonna be a pole with
your pocket for the rest of your life so
it was my answer I've had a lot of
coffee today John can I basically do
whatever feels good when it comes to
soap you know John do whatever feels
good when it comes to soap know that
that's that's good to hear because I
have often wondered about that and
worried about that like am i doing some
damage to my skin and it's good to hear
that if it feels all right I probably am
all right and it's nice to hear that
from a beauty expert like yourself Hank
the next question comes from Jeff Roe
who asks Dear John and Hank a friend of
a friend believes the earth is flat they
are clearly wrong strong agree but I
want to know what you guys think how
could I best argue against them when
they say science and politicians are
lying to them they also say they should
be allowed to believe whatever they want
and Who am I to stop them am i right to
want other people not to be wrong oh
this seems to me a question that is not
really about whether the earth is flat
but instead about this weird post fact
world that we are living in where memes
have taken on a kind of truth to them
that is totally disconnected from what I
think of as reality yes uh this is an
interesting question because there's the
first part which is like how can I argue
with this person who clearly just wants
to argue and that's like that's their
main goal and having this ludicrous
believe right which don't yep and then
the other one is like like how do I come
to terms with the fact that like being
wrong like like like isn't there just
something wrong with being wrong and
can't we agree on that right right right
with this idea that like that that
people say well I should be allowed to
believe whatever I want it it's very
difficult to disagree with that I
totally agree with you like don't get in
arguments with people who just say
things to be provocative like I used to
work with someone who would regularly
say that that Abraham Lincoln was the
worst American president and there's
only one reason to say that right which
is to try to start an argument you know
any time anybody would bring up the 19th
century they would be like well as you
know Abraham Lincoln was the worst
American president you know and that's
just like a dot dot dot and then you
have to be like you know hi hmm I mean
he wasn't he wasn't he wasn't the worst
it's probably probably in the top two
probably not one anyway
as you can tell I'm still a little
annoyed about that and but I just it is
it's really difficult you can't engage
when people with people I don't think
it's effective to engage with people
when they're merely being provocateurs
because of the never wrestle with a pig
axiom you know you you get dirty and
besides the pig likes it the problem is
that we seem to be living in this time
we're both wrestling with the pig and
not wrestling with the pig are equally
ineffective and I feel totally powerless
and clueless about how we're supposed to
be proceeding as people who believe in
in in science and people who believe in
facts and I just feel like we've become
unmoored from what I think of as as like
fundamental reality and it freaks me out
and I don't know what to do about it
yeah I mean there's this this great
thing that happened called the
Enlightenment
where we where we kind of all finally
agreed that there was a way to get to
objective knowledge and and had a path
to that and it's almost like that
there's at the moment some kind of anti
enlightenment happening and I agree that
right it's more than anti
intellectualism right like it goes
deeper than anti-intellectualism
claiming the earth is flat is not just a
rejection of the sort of like you know
intellectual elite it's a rejection of
fairly fundamental observable knowledge
and and it's imagining a world in which
so many people are lying to you that
it's just that's what seems so weird to
me about it yeah well I mean the thing
like flat earthers honestly don't bother
me
because there aren't very many of them
and and it's clearly ludicrous but like
the you know people who deny the
existence of global warming bother me
like that right it's just like this is a
thing that we are going to have to deal
with as a species and the longer weak
argue about whether it exists the less
we're going to be able to do and and I
think that there are a number of like
you know it's almost as if that data has
become the enemy of of the Enlightenment
where there is so much data now that
there will always be a study saying
something that is you know contrary to
the big body biggest body of evidence
and so you can latch on to those
individual points you know and I will
say that like I don't think science has
the solution for every problem
I think that there are lots of good
reasons to have other ways to examine
the world but I you know I am very you
know it's like a legitimate worry that I
have right now and it expresses me out
this you know ya know it stresses me out
too I also think that you know people
end up not having these conversations
like across belief systems in ways that
are really problematic like when we're
talking about climate change being real
which it is and it's in arguable that
it's real and it's an arguable that that
humans are causing it
we are 95 percent preaching to the choir
right like we are so siloed one of the
shocking responses to the nerdfighter
census at least to me is that they're
you know are tens of thousands of people
who filled out this census and in the
question who do you plan to vote for for
president Hillary Clinton is
overwhelmingly in first place Gary
Johnson is in second place Jill Stein is
in third place and Donald Trump got four
percent support so far and within within
people who identify as as nerdfighters I
mean that that level of disconnect like
that means that what I have always
thought of as like a fairly and
occlusive community that that's you know
fairly representative of American life
within certain you know age demographics
really isn't at all you have the other
thing is that three percent of those
four percent said that they were
begrudging lis supporting Donald Trump
because they saw him as the lesser of
two evils like only 1% of our community
is enthusiastic and their support for
Donald Trump and yet you know thirty
percent of likely voters are and that is
forty forty five percent of likely
voters according to a poll that came out
today it's very it's a very weird time
and and I agree with you Hank that that
data has in some ways become the enemy
of science because it's so easy to
cherry-pick data now and and it's really
sad and there's also I think I think
something about the internet and I I
worry that we feed into this a little
bit leads everybody to feel like they
can become experts in something in ten
to twelve minutes and and I worry
sometimes that that we feed that belief
even though we try to be we try to be
pretty careful because the belief itself
seems to me really really destructive
and really dangerous because then you've
got people who say well I know climate
science is wrong because this person
says it's wrong and you know here are
two studies and that's that it's really
weird it's such a weird stressful time
in American political life and you know
we are gonna you and I personally like
are much less at risk from from this
stuff than then the people who are most
in need of the protection of a
government and yeah so so we're coming
at this from a very privileged
privileged place but it is scary I think
no matter who you all yeah so Jethro I
think that the answer to your question
is that you are right to want other
people to not be wrong but that we do
not know how to get the world to a place
where we can have those conversations
effectively oh god no we really don't
and let's just have silence for the next
45 seconds while we mourn you really
messed up our groove there Jethro we're
having a good time
today's podcast is brought to you by the
DAR
miss the darkness encroaching today's
podcast is also brought to you by
mushrooms they are not a vegetable not a
fruit not even a plant but they are a
vegetable that's actually a really good
tagline for mushrooms mushrooms not a
vegetable not a fruit just a vegetable
and of course today's podcast is also
brought to you by the queen wave the
queen wave the number one way to make
sure that people understand that you
appreciate the Happy Birthday song
and finally this podcast is brought to
you by 378 healthy human bodies
delivered straight to your door from
health gov man poor health gov they're
trying they're trying that's that's what
they that's what they do I sort of feel
like we serve ourselves out of the
darkness from Jethro's question but only
sort of let's move on to another
question Hank this question comes from
sahitya who writes Dear John and Hank
I'm currently in the process of applying
to medical school and like many people I
know I've had negative experiences with
health care providers in the US it's
alarmingly common for patients to feel
dehumanized dismissed and ignored I know
both of you have spoken about your
experiences with chronic illness and
John has talked about his experience as
a hospital chaplain what ways have you
seen health care professionals provide
compassionate care I should say that
while I have had some negative
experiences with my care definitely I've
also had a lot of really really positive
ones I have a awesome doctor and I've
had a few great ER visits my neurologist
when I had viral meningitis was just
amazing I just like let us now pause to
give thanks for my amazing neurologist
when I had meningitis I I think usually
when I've had not great care and I don't
know how you feel about this Hank but I
usually feel like it's because it's a
hard job like providing medical care is
really really hard and on a
second-by-second basis it's almost
impossible to remember that each of
these people when you're going from
person to person to person that each of
these people is under a tremendous
amount of stress that they're having a
really difficult day in their lives and
and to try to be as as patient and
careful as you need to be is really
really hard and I think everybody's
gonna fail at it sometimes it's just you
know the important thing I think is
remembering that yeah that these are
that these are human beings and that the
the care that you're providing the
medical side of it is is important but
making sure that people understand that
they feel safe that they know what's
happening that's that's as important as
the medical part I think in a lot of
cases yeah and I feel like I don't know
if this is accurate but like in my
experience with doctors I feel like like
there is training that goes on to help
them with this stuff that to get better
at it into and yeah but it's not always
adequate training like I remember when I
was when I was a hospital chaplain I
remember a doctor like pulled me out of
a room with a family and she was very
young doctor and she was like I can't I
can't do this and I was like excuse me
and she was like I can't I can't talk to
them right now
and I was like what do you mean she was
like can you just tell them and I was
like no like yeah I'm not a doctor I was
like I literally I literally can't
because of the law we're gonna have to
like we're gonna have to like man up and
do this together like yeah I mean I do I
do see it is like there's a very weird
thing being a doctor it's so hard go
through you go through so much education
so that you can be a good doctor
and then you are also expected to
provide excellent customer support and
yeah those are different skill sets and
and and it can often be like did I spend
all of this time just like becoming you
know like becoming this like a doctor in
order to get yelled at by someone
because I made a mistake which I'm gonna
do sometimes right yeah there's the like
there's the organic chemistry side of
being a doctor or or any health care
professional really and then there's the
side where you just thought yeah I mean
that stuff is so stressful ah yeah I
anyway thank you for applying to medical
school
we wish you luck Hank and I would both
be terrible doctors yeah I mean yeah I
think I think as long as you're thinking
about it then that's that's a really
good sign and and my experience is
having I have also had really great
doctors and and have very few nasty
things to say about them but I you know
I think that that is also true of most
of the interactions I have in my life so
I think that you know like bad
experiences tend to stick out in
people's heads and then there are some
people who have lots of bad experiences
because they themselves are just very
difficult people to work with and that
is not not a thing that is also true
although it should also be noted that
this is another place where being white
and male is provably yeah it's true as
true easier it's true and living in an
affluent community where there is by are
plenty of resources to support you know
good good hospitals with doctors who
want to live in those communities and it
is a it is a world of inequality and I'm
on the good side of that curve yeah it
is a very deep systemic thing inequality
and it's like really hard to even like
acknowledge or think about all the
different ways that it factors into a
human life but I definitely feel that
when I am at the hospital
I definitely feel aware of it when I'm
at the hospital Hank I wanted to get to
one last question because it's just very
important before we get to the
all-important news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon this question comes from Sarah
and she writes dear John and Hank over
the years I've participated in many
activities and sports that make me feel
nervous prior to the activity sand along
with feeling nervous I always have to
poop it's not just the gut clenching
feeling I'll actually have to make a
trip to the bathroom several of my
friends have also agreed that they get
the nervous poops prior to an event so I
was wondering if you knew why this is I
like this question and I like Sarah
because she had the courage to ask it
not even on anonymous ly though Sarah's
pretty anonymous well but I mean she
says that she talks to her friends about
it where she's just like do you guys get
the nervous poops yeah I do by the way
this is a real thing this is a very very
real
and it seems to be a it seems to be a
side effect of adrenaline it makes you
have to pee it makes you have to poop
and like people will make like talk
about reasons why this is a good thing
if you're gonna fight or flight' - no
it's not don't worry I never never do i
what yeah and i don't want to have
another thing to start worrying about if
i'm about totally agree a tiger like and
do you think it's not gonna eat me just
cuz i got a little poop on my leg no
it's gonna eat me i'm food yeah no I
totally agree with you I think that
there's absolutely no evolutionary
advantage in in pooping the moment
before you get attacked by a grizzly
bear there is this thing called the gut
brain axis that I am totally fascinated
by where your your gastrointestinal
tract and your brain actually talk a lot
to each other a lot more than then other
parts of your body talk to your brain in
in many cases and part of that also is
that the bacteria in your
gastrointestinal tract I've been reading
this great book called I contain
multitudes that talks a lot about this
you know the bacteria in your
gastrointestinal tract like give off
different chemicals and different signs
and and so it may also be partly that
that when you get anxious the the gut
brain axis starts you know firing
signals of anxiety back and forth until
you know suddenly you have to poop but
it's okay it's normal
mm-hm and I just hope for your sake that
it doesn't interfere with your sports or
other activities yeah the traditional
medical explanation for this is that you
you when adrenaline starts running your
body moves resources away from your core
and into your limbs which are necessary
for fighting and running and stuff and
also that's good for for sports but and
that means that it is moving resources
away from your digestive system and it
might think like oh like let's just
abandon all of this and maybe things
relax but also there's some amount I
think of cramping that happens so it's
not just like that all your sphincters
relax it's all of that like there's like
some peristalsis waves of muscle
contractions going down your Co and
being like okay let's empty this out
because we're not going to deal with it
we don't want to deal with this right
now we're gonna deal with other things
there's gonna be other things to deal
with so let's just stop
digesting right now get rid of
everything in the digestive system and
not worry about that you're making me a
little nervous just by talking about
this do you not like the word
peristalsis cuz I love it such a fun
word it might be that might be the
problem it's more that I don't like
imagining I don't really like imagining
what's happening on the inside of me
very much I find it deeply threatening
to my sense of self I have to have with
that said let's move on to the news from
Mars and AFC Wimbledon hick what's the
news from Mars this week right if you I
don't know if you've seen if you follow
me on Twitter or tumblr you probably
have curiosity has sent back some images
as it has begun to traverse away from
the the ancient lake bed that it has
been hanging out and into the mountains
surrounding that lake bed and as it has
done that the the topography has become
much more interesting and much cooler in
the photographs that it's sending back
have been gorgeous and they just
released a few of these that they did
some good post-production on showing not
just you know really cool Geographic
landscapes and like some vistas and you
know like basically it looks a lot like
sort of old old like 1870s photographs
of the American Southwest but also that
like taking close-up shots of cliff
faces that are very clearly layer after
layer after layer like hundreds of
layers of sediment laid down likely
either in a lake like a Lakes Lake
situation or in a stream situation and
that just it isn't like the more time we
spend on Mars the more it's like oh we
thought that this was you know a place
where there you know there's no water no
life but for a long time there was a lot
of water on the surface of Mars and and
the more time we spend there and the
more we see it and also that like what
that leads to is you know scientific
interest for sure but also like the
action of water in a geological system
is also just aesthetically really
pleasing and even after that water has
been gone for a long long time the the
forms that were left by that water
spending time on the surface of the
planet
doing cool things remains just beautiful
and so like as much as this news is not
about the science of Mars it is just
about the aesthetics of Mars I think
you should look at those pictures
because it's it's wonderful it's
wonderful to have such a high quality
set of imaging systems on the surface of
Mars right now and also on in such a
geographically diverse and interesting
place on the surface of Mars as well
well I have to say that I completely
agree with you about how aesthetically
beautiful it is to see the remnants of
waters work on on on earth or stone so
for once I'm pretty psyched to check out
these Mars pictures but I will emphasize
that it's easy to take them without
putting any human beings on Mars at
least until 2028 or later and there's an
article in The Wall Street Journal right
now that compares these photographs to
photographs from Timothy O'Sullivan the
19th century philosopher photographer he
might also benefit aren't all
photographers philosophers of a kind
well the news from the news from AFC
Wimbledon somewhat less aesthetically
beautiful heartbreaking gut-wrenching
3-2 loss to Sheffield United last week
huh you know some encouraging news this
new player Dom poliansky a goal
Tom Elliot came on in the second half
and scored a goal but the Dons defense
continues to let in too many goals and
playing from behind too often giving up
leads too often we found all the major
ways to lose and right now not at the
very bottom where we were after the
first couple games so I guess that's
good news but with five points after
seven games AFC Wimbledon our 21st which
is the last relegation spot or the first
relegation spots so if this season were
to end today they would be relegated
back to League Two side note a
semi-related
thing that that it would be it will be
of some interest to AFC Wimbledon fans
the franchise currently playing in
Milton Keynes has played seven games
has only eight points so is currently
sitting in 15th place in Ligue 1 not too
terribly far from AFC Wimbledon Swindon
Town a team that used to play FIFA as
for a long time is in 16th also having a
difficult season in Ligue 1 so it's been
uh you know it's it's been a long seven
games but hopefully I don't know yeah
we'll see the the season is long I get
to go to a game soon I'm excited about
that
good I'm also excited about that and and
the chances of it being a really
fantastic experience though John seemed
low oh wait what's that I just saying
that like you're probably gonna go watch
your team loose I'm sorry oh yeah yeah I
mean statistically that is probably
what's going to happen but you never
know uh anything is possible and I'm
going to keep my my fingers crossed and
alright well John thank you for the news
from AFC Wimbledon what did we learn
today we learned that Abraham Lincoln
was America's worst president is the
kind of thing that you say if you want
to start an argument we learned that
humans are ugly naked apes because of
original sin I don't think that's
actually what we learned we've learned
that old people will always like
classical music and we learned that of
course William Carlos Williams was a big
proponent of taking baths in yogurt warm
yogurt big tubs full of yogurt and I'm
totally not making that up at all it
seems very plausible to me thanks for
listening Hank thank you for podding
with me you can email us at Hank and
John at gmail.com you can also follow us
on patreon or support the podcast
directly on patreon at patreon.com slash
dear Hank and John again our email
address is Hank and John at gmail.com
Nicholas Jenkins edited version halse
rojas helps out with questions our theme
music is by gunnarolla I'm John Green on
Twitter Hank is Hank green on Twitter if
you want to say hi to us there you can
also use the hashtag dear Hank and John
we get some questions that way thank you
again for listening and as we say in our
hometown right right wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait also starting this week
we
Victoria buongiorno who is running dear
Hank and John helping out with the
patreon and with social media stuff and
also of various other things taking over
for Claudia is Victoria hello Victoria
Thank You Victoria
I apologize for missing your name in
your very first week on the job
ah and as they say in our hometown don't
forget to be awesome
[Music]